can you show some traps in the queen's
gambit
should we take a small break should we
just
like have a lesson on traps in the
queen's gambit the most basic trap
is a queen's gambit accepted trap
which uh a lot of noobs will fall into
yeah almost two million people have
taken
the pawn which is a completely fine
opening
but the trap to um to kind of
get a lot of beginner players in is to
play e3 here
let's say black plays b5 and then a4
now we just follow the most common move
c6
takes this might be one of the most
common traps
in chess like there's not too many traps
where
over at least according to the database
where over 20 000 people
walk into it but yeah queen f3 just uh
just
wins the rook um i assume most people
have seen this before
but if you're new to chess then um
it's a nice one to know because black
just took a pawn and tried to defend it
and then gets punished
so the question i'm really curious
who's the highest rated player that has
fallen into this
man 2700 that's crazy
i feel kind of sad for these people
[Music]
like 26 2 500 plus players
walking into one of like the most common
traps in chess
but maybe you could treat it can you
treat it as a gamut
queen b6 this
no you can't really trap the queen you
want to play this but you lose more
material
so this is a nice one after a4 black is
already under
massive massive pressure um if a6 we
take and there's a pin
and there's some fun lines like bishop
d7
um bring back the
all the games you can take bishop takes
and then you can ask stockfish but
yeah white's already having a nice
advantage
yeah bishop moves and we win the pawn
um i can share some more advanced traps
too
i could share a trap for black the the
famous elephant trap
turn off stockfish the elephant trap
is against the queen's gambit
you go into this position probably one
of the
most common positions actually let's say
white takes first
but you can you can get this from
multiple different move orders
and then here you play knight d7
and then you say oh no my pawn
so over 5000 people took on d5 here
which is a blunder so you can also get
it from this move order if bishop g5
knight d7 also sets up the trap or it
looks like white can just win the pawn
the problem is
most people know you take on d5 and then
you say oh no my queen
but then you win white's queen right
back queen d2 only legal move
takes takes and black has an extra
knight in this position
so i learned this from a very young age
some nice memories getting this and uh
probably got this in at least
one over the board tournament game when
playing scholastic chess
so i think between the first one and
this one these are like the most
the two most common traps in the queen's
gambit
i can show more though
so how many people fell for this so
almost 5500 the next one i'll show
it's another trap where you're black
it's another pretty
like famous one but i'm sure there's
people watching who haven't seen it
before
it starts with e5 known as the album
counter gambit
so rather than accepting the gambit
black gamut's upon
you play d4 and the trap
actually begins after white's next move
and this is a case where one of white's
most natural looking moves is actually a
key mistake
a move being e3 which looks very normal
you want to remove this pawn drake
queens
and simplify um
let's see how many players played e3
and 27 000.
this might actually be more common than
the elephant trap
and this is the start of a really
beautiful line
i think i'm going to spoil it just
because it's hard to imagine from this
position
but within the next five moves black is
gonna under promote to a knight
and it's like all the best moves for
black
um that's hard to imagine like promoting
to a night
anytime soon here but it's going to be
like the icing on the cake of the trap
i'm saying that because the people who
haven't seen this before
it'll it'll keep them watching so the
move is bishop b4
check white will play like most natural
bishop d2
i think we can just follow the most
common moves yeah bishop d2
take on e3
uh so more people take back but
over 6 600 people took the bishop
it helps if you say oh no my bishop
white will be more likely to take and
then
yeah then we take on f2
and now the point is we're attracting
the king
we're deflecting the king away from
defending the queen so if takes we just
win the queen
so white will play king e2 and now this
is a position
where it's best to take and not promote
to a queen if you promote to queen you
give white the option of taking
and this is actually fine for white this
is equal material
but you promote tonight
only way to promote and check the king
and then if rook takes we we skewer and
we win the queen
um so we can see on each us
yeah almost 5 000 games like most people
who
go into this position know to promote
tonight
it's actually sad like the people who
played bishop g4
um is this is now better for white
because there's knight f3
so yeah f takes g one knight
and then the best move is actually king
e1
[Music]
and here we're not actually winning the
queen but we have a crushing position
after queen h4
and we just randomly have a knight on g1
so main line is
let's say king d2
[Music]
it's so funny too because we have three
knights on the board
within the first 10 moves
knight c6
i wonder if there's some lines where
this knight survives
bishop c3 this is actually really funny
queenside castling with check
94
92.
okay anyway so that's uh the main trap
in the albin
that uh i mean unsuspecting players i
think it's very easy to
kind of play e3 and stumble into this
um do i share more do people want to see
more queen's gambit traps
i shared three already
some of the most common traps
trying to think of another one oh
there's one there's one
i actually fell into when i was younger
i was like 1600
it's actually kind of common you can get
a lot of players who
try playing a reverse london
so it starts as a sloth and it emerges
let's say block plays play c6
and then goes for like natural
development with knight f6 and bishop f5
so essentially we get this position
okay different move orders but uh if
black plays this going for
reverse london then
i think black has already basically
walked into the trap
i should know we're switching back so
now white is going to be trapping black
how many people have reached this
position wow
i might have to take back what i said
earlier because earlier i was saying
like the first chat made maybe the the
most common it's probably the most
famous
but this one this one's going to branch
out but there's we're going to have
lines where white's much better in
most every variation so the key move to
play is c takes d5
c takes d5 and then queen b3
so over 51 000 games from here
and the point is we're pressuring the
queen side
and it's really hard to figure out the
best
way to defend is black
real quick okay so most people either
play
this or this
um i want to ask chat
to find the best move for black in this
position
the best move is kind of ridiculous yeah
black to move trying to find the best
move
some people sing queen g7
oh king d7 is probably the most
ridiculous move
but it's it's not king d7 queen diggs e1
would also be ridiculous
but also slightly illegal
yeah good job to everyone saying bishop
c8
black in order to hold on to everything
black has to undevelop the bishop
and then white's just uh having a
pleasant game
and just um yeah more development and
way more development like four pieces
developed compared to one piece for
black
so most players won't play bishop c8
most players uh we can see actually play
queen b6
um which loses a pawn to
the simple knight takes d5 feels bad man
bishop
oh oh yeah it feels bad when you're
black and you have to play
bishop c8 but it feels good if you're
white
and the point here is that if queen
takes queen we don't take back because
then we lose our knight but we take the
check
zwischenzug in between move and then
whatever takes
back uh lights up a healthy pawn
has two center pawns for zero center
pawns
so how many people play queen b6
seventeen thousand
now if we look at the other line b6 this
b6 line is actually a bit more beautiful
it will lead to more crashing advantage
for white
the continuation here actually starts
with a normal move bishop g5
just simply developing but also keeping
initiative
we're threatening to take and win the
pawn so the best move for black is
um or i don't know if it's the best move
but it's the most common
move of course is e6
most common by far
and now this is another puzzle for chat
white to move and find the beautiful way
to
destroy black's hopes and dreams
hello there thanks for subbing sure fine
whatever
just drawing arrows for the legal moves
that i see suggested
queen b7 slightly illegal
okay good job to people saying e4
sacking upon but keeping initiative
like it's so easy for black to stumble
into this position
like from early in the opening too
so we only have one defender
but the point is we hit the bishop and
we threaten bishop b5
so regardless of how that captures
okay if night captures we win the queen
most people take with pawn
we play bishop b5 uh knight d7
and then after 95 white is guaranteed to
win
a piece because both knights are pinned
and there's no way to defend the threat
is just to take
this knight first actually the threat is
to take either knight
because the knights don't really defend
each other
so move like bishop e7 breaking the pin
then we take this knight first
and then take the other knight and life
is good
the king can't castle we're threatening
discoveries
so let's see how many people played e4
okay um oh most people play e3
which is also strong but e4 i believe is
the strongest
so super venomous um a nice line to know
in queen's gambit
and it's one reason why like when you're
playing against queen's gambit
you have to be very careful developing
this bishop early
because when queen b3 happens you can
fall in trouble very quickly
okay so how many chops was that
let's recap we saw the queen's gambit
accepted trap
we saw we just saw the the slav
like reverse london gone wrong trap
and we saw the elephant trap for black
which was the one where we say oh no my
pawn and then oh no my queen
so this one we also saw the album
counter gamut under promotion to night
trap
do i share one more i'll share one more
just to make it five
that's a nicer number for a future
youtube title
so this next one will be
against the queen's gambit it will be
called the cambridge springs
um actually it involves white playing
like all the natural moves
so white's gonna just play the natural
queen's gambit setup
and then fall victim into a trap so all
these arrows i drew
black will play or white will play and
then black will be trapping white
so the setup will be you can actually
start with with elephant trap
if you want and let's imagine white
doesn't take
but just continues developing
so so far both sides really solid black
built the triangle
[Music]
structure and after the next move
queen a5 this is the start of the
cambridge springs
um it's a cool it's a cool move because
we
we create the pin against tonight we
have ideas of this and this
and then the bishop is also a target in
some variations
and we break the pin so
one of the more natural looking moves
for white
even though okay so it's not the most
common move
but it's still played
almost 9 000 times is bishop d3
and bishop d3 is is a mistake here
because white can take take
this one i'll just go ahead and show um
is to play knight e4 and this is a fork
we're threatening the bishop and the
knight
twice with our knight but also our
longest and i've queen 25 months
oh thank you lord francesco welcome back
30 months equals free lesson right lola
oh maybe remind me in five months
i should offer something for the long
time subs
anyway this is one kind of big free
lesson
it's also one big triangle a nice little
[Music]
what do you call a triangle where all
those sides are different lengths
because there's equilateral there's
isosceles
scalene man i haven't heard the word
scalene in so long
anyway um yeah the queen and knight
coordinate beautifully here
and what's funny about this position
is yeah almost 700 people don't realize
their bishop is hanging
they'll play queen c2 and you just win a
bishop so it's hard to see the queen
like
is so far away still can capture on g5
of course it's better for white to save
the bishop and then we
take the knight and then take
we're not winning this because there's
knight d2 but we have some nice pressure
we're up a pawn and black is for choice
here
we are threatening to take this too so
white still has to be careful
oh mesopotamia and with that
that's all the traps i have for now so
maybe i'll do
i'll have to prepare more traps for the
future but hopefully hopefully people
got some value
from that um i'll almost certainly put
this on youtube